überfall in berlin köpenick nach einem
banküberfall und einer geiselnahme hat
die berliner polizei einen mutmaßlichen
täter gefasst drei stunden nach dem
ersten alarm vorher habe die polizei
längere zeit in kontakt mit dem
verdächtigen gestanden er habe zwei
frauen und einen mann in einer
postfiliale bedroht hunde uns den
neuesten stand von unserem reporter
peter wicke er ist vor ort hat die
situation beobachtet peter ist denn
jetzt alles wieder ruhig sind die
geiseln in sicherheit ist der täter
festgenommen
ja aktuell wurde hier die straße sehen
uns wieder aufgemacht die menschen
können wir wieder herumlaufen der
verkehr läuft die da hier kam es eben
heute zu dieser bedrohungslage in der
postbank filiale im forum köpenick einem
einkaufscenter hier im osten berlins
die polizei war mit 200 kräften vor ort
außerdem war ein team der spezial-
einsatzkräfte vor ort und jetzt bei mir
pressesprecher der berliner polizei
halbig herwig was können sie denn jetzt
zum aktuellen stand sagen wie genau kam
es zur befreiung der person und zur
festnahme des täters
unsere spezial einsatzkräfte konnten in
einem günstigen augenblick am günstigen
zeitpunkt zu greifen und den täter
festnehmen und ihn überwältigen
es war leicht verletzt worden bei der
festnahme wird aktuell durch
rettungskräfte der feuerwehr unter
polizeibegleitung in ein krankenhaus
gebracht die übrigen drei personen in
der bankfiliale möglicherweise
unverletzt sie werden jetzt aktuell
gefragt und vernommen durch unsere
mittleren und ermittler
und wer genau hat sie eigentlich
alarmiert zudem also als der
bedrohungslage in der filiale kann die
polizei berlin ist gegen 14 uhr aus der
bankfiliale heraus alarmiert worden zur
bedrohung innerhalb der bankfiliale zum
art und umfang der alarmierung jetzt
können wir nach jetzigem stand noch
keinen größeren angaben machen
wir haben aktuell nicht vorliegen ob das
über ein alarmsystem oder über
eigentlichen telefon verfolgen was genau
passiert jetzt noch im hintergrund also
wir haben die kriminaltechnik gesehen in
der filiale selbst finden jetzt noch
tatort arbeiten sparen das heißt also
spezialisten sind hier vor ort jetzt
spuren sichern zum beispiel
fingerabdruck spuren dns-spuren die
beweismittel in der bankfiliale sichern
um die ermittlungen entsprechend
aufführen zu können
im weiteren verlauf wird natürlich dann
auch der tatverdächtige zu seiner
motivation zu sein geschehen hier zu
seinem handeln gefragt werden zudem
bislang noch völlig unklar ist ja so war
ich hier aus köpenick also erstmal
entwarnung hier und damit zurück ins
studio
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren